digamos que tenemos un tubo nuevamente y
esta va a ser la abertura
y tenemos un fluído que va a estar
entrando en este tubo
va a entrar con una velocidad de 1 a ese
tubo
la presión de entrada al tubo también
base es
y el área de esta abertura más es a 1
esta tubería tiene una forma muy curiosa
va a estar más o menos así va a subir
y también se va a gustar
de manera que esta base es la sección de
salida
es más pequeña el área el área de salida
la vamos a llamar a 2 va a tener una
velocidad de salida que también vamos a
llamar b 2 y una presión de salida que
adivinaron este subíndice 2 además la
abertura de entrada se va a encontrar
a una altura h 1 del nivel del suelo y
la abertura de salida se va a encontrar
a una altura
h 2 y como pueden ver esta altura de
salida va a ser mayor que la altura de
entrada
con esta configuración y recordando que
por aquí va a pasar un fluido ahora
recordemos que aquí hay mucha
conservación de la energía y que en
cualquier sistema cerrado la cantidad de
energía que se pone a la entrada debe
ser igual a la cantidad de energía que
está a la salida la energía al entrar
debe ser igual a la energía de salida y
cuál va a ser la energía de entrada o la
energía con la que se inicia este
sistema pues va a ser el trabajo de
entrada trabajo de entrada
más la energía potencial en este punto
del sistema energía potencial
de entrada
más la energía cinética en este punto de
sistema energía cinética o cinética
y sabemos que por la conservación de la
energía esto todo esto tiene que ser
igual
el trabajo de salida que se encuentra en
este extremo
más la energía potencial de salida aquí
es la energía cinética a la salida
en muchas ocasiones anteriores veíamos
que la energía potencial de entrada más
la energía cinética de entrada era igual
a la energía potencial de salida más la
energía cinética de salida pero la
energía inicial del sistema también
puede venir del trabajo por lo que
agregamos esta sección del trabajo en
esta ecuación y ahora con toda esta
información vemos que podemos hacer
interesante con este tubo que acabo de
dibujar
veamos cuál es el trabajo que se está
poniendo en este sistema el trabajo es
la fuerza por la distancia
enfoquémonos en esto el trabajo de
entrada
es la fuerza de entrada por la distancia
de entrada
y consideramos la distancia recorrida en
un período de tiempo t en el vídeo
anterior vimos que en un período de
tiempo t el fluido de aquí se movió
hasta acá vamos a dibujarlo el fluido
que estaba aquí
se movió
hasta acá
esta distancia y cuál es esta distancia
pues es mi velocidad 1 por el tiempo
será la fuerza bueno la fuerza es la
presión entre el área y la podemos
calcular dividiendo esta fuerza
efe la fuerza de entrada fuerza de
entrada
entre el área de entrada
y la vamos a multiplicar por el área de
entrada para que no se afecte si
dividimos algo y lo multiplicamos por
eso mismo vamos a dejar la cantidad
igual y esto lo vamos a multiplicar por
la distancia en ese instante que es
nuestra velocidad 1
por el tiempo
el trabajo de entrada va a ser igual así
que el trabajo de entrada lo vamos a
escribir por acá es igual a la presión 1
por el área 1 x
la velocidad 1 por el tiempo
y cuál va a ser esta área
por la velocidad
por la distancia pues es el volumen del
líquido que fluye durante esta cantidad
de tiempo
esto de aquí
es igual al volumen lo pongo con
mayúscula de entrada
y sabemos que la densidad de saleh
escribo por acá la densidad
vamos a escribir aquí
es igual a la masa entre el volumen
en mayúscula para que sigamos
en el entendido de que la b mayúscula es
volumen
y podemos decir también que el volumen
por la densidad es igual a la masa o
podemos decir que el volumen es igual a
la masa entre la densidad todas estas
son equivalencias así que el trabajo que
estoy poniendo dentro del sistema
sé que estoy escribiendo muchas cosas
pero verán que tienen sentido el trabajo
que estoy polino dentro del sistema es
igual a la presión de entrada y presión
de entrada multiplicada por la cantidad
de volumen que pasa en ese lapso de
tiempo
y esa cantidad de volumen es igual a la
masa del fluido
entonces es esta presión de entrada por
la masa de entrada que pasó en ese
tiempo y que llamamos masa de entrada
dividido entre la densidad esto entre la
densidad espero que esto tenga sentido
para ustedes y como sabemos el volumen
de entrada será igual al volumen de
salida y la masa de entrada ya que la
densidad no va a cambiar en todo este
sistema va a ser igual a la masa de
salida la masa será constante en el
sistema durante cualquier instante del
tiempo de manera que la masa que entra
va a ser igual a la masa que sale
así que nos ha quedado una expresión
bastante interesante con respecto al
trabajo que entra al sistema ahora vamos
a ver la energía potencial la energía
potencial de entrada
esta va a ser igual
a esa misma masa del fluido que entra a
la masa
multiplicada por la gravedad
multiplicada por la altura de entrada
que vimos que es h
y cuando hacer la energía cinética
inicial del fluido la energía cinética
vamos a ponerlo en otro color
la energía cinética de entrada va a ser
igual a la masa del fluido m
que entran multiplicada por la velocidad
del fluido al cuadrado velocidad de
entrada al cuadrado y eso lo recordamos
de la fórmula de energía cinética todo
esto va a estar dividido entre 2 vuelve
a ser la energía total en este punto del
sistema durante este periodo de tiempo
cuánta energía ha entrado en el sistema
pues bueno va a ser el trabajo realizado
y me estoy dando cuenta que mexicanos y
en el espacio y quizás sin tiempo por lo
que voy a mover aquí
esto para tener un poquito más de
espacio
bueno entonces la energía a la entrada
total va a ser la potencia 1 por la masa
entre la densidad más
la masa por la gravedad por la altura 1
más la masa por la velocidad de entrada
al cuadrado entre 2 esto es un 1
y esto viene esta sección es de el
trabajo de entrada esta sección viene de
la energía potencial de entrada y esta
sección viene de la energía cinética de
entrar
y sabemos que todo esto debe ser igual a
la energía que sale del sistema
por lo que esto va a ser igual vamos a
ponerlo en otro color
a todos estos mismos elementos pero a la
salida del sistema que es igual a la
presión cero voy a regresar un poquito
hacia arriba para que vean de qué
hablamos
perdón no es presión cero expresión
2 vamos a corregirlo aquí
presión 2
por la masa que sólo cambia entre la
densidad que tampoco va a cambiar más la
masa por la gravedad por la altura 2 más
la masa por la velocidad a la salida
que estas velocidades de minúsculas para
diferenciarlo del volumen al cuadrado
entre 2
y me acabo de dar cuenta que se me acaba
el tiempo por lo que continuaremos con
esto en el siguiente vídeo